Hey [inaudible] I remember Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and today we're talking about the escape scanning.
This last story,
I have a feeling that this guy actually does kind of make it through.
This is a true, I think he does honest escape,
but he does it in the most original and most unusual.
Hey here where the story is our producer Sean Cole.
So the story starts in the late fifties there was this little boy in Richmond,
Virginia named Joe and Grassy, a junior.
He's seven or eight years old and he's just sitting at home dialing various
numbers on his parent's telephone just to see what happens.
He was on a long distance call to information, you know, five, five,
five one two, one two and to just an area code. This is Phil Lapsley.
I first heard Joe's story from him and he heard it
very faintly in the background, the tone,
and you just started whistling along with it and all of a sudden he heard a
critique
and the call went away and it turns out that the tone in the background of the
phone and his corresponding whistle was 2,600 hertz.
Musically it's about seventh [inaudible]. So he has perfect pitch. Yeah.
And he was weirdly smart as you'll soon
discover anyway, he thinks to himself. That's very odd. Well,
that happened once. I wonder if it could happen again. Does it again?
He didn't even really know exactly what it was at the time, but he does it.
Yeah.
Again, and again,
he didn't think it was particularly useful for anything.
He does talk about walking past, uh,
somebody at a pay phone when he was seven or eight years old and whistling this
tone and uh, having the phone and the phone call, disconnect on the person. Wow.
That's amazing. Super power. That really is. Yeah.
Which means he could be a little walking bomb.
He could go to grand central station where there many people sitting in phone
booths and as he could make them all lose their phone calls. Yeah.
And no one would know. Right. But it was more than just a cool trick for him.
This discovery was the beginning.
I have a kind of escape.
Oh, what were you scared of when you were a little, I bet something
scared me. I don't know remember how old I was, but
it's all we have left of him. In fact,
he died in 2007 but he left behind hours and hours of recordings of his voice
phone recordings. And as he listened to them
that was afraid, you know, something might have grown out of the bed.
What found the button on the floor. And
you pretty quickly realized that the little boy in that room who was playing
with the phone, he was kind of desperate. Really. Um,
he went to this Catholic school for the blind was his mind. He was born blind.
And when he was there
in the fall of 1955, this got pretty bad.
A lot of the nuns where me and my sister really hard, you know, and shut.
The only one that the will abuse.
She used to have me get on the table.
Then she wouldn't get up on the table and lie down.
She did the bad touching.
Things were pretty bad at home too.
Daddy wouldn't slam mother and her and break things and lots of scary sounds and
stuff at night that has my phone up close to the dial tone
[inaudible] too.
I'm on a dial tone there.
It's a nice warm tone. It never yelled at, never fought.
One on wonderful thing of telephone is
well, just a nice way for him to comfort himself
during those long nights.
And so how does exactly did the, the whistling thing he was doing,
how did that help him? Yeah. Well
it takes a few steps to explain,
but it turns out that that tone was the key word in a hidden mechanical language
that controlled the phone system.
He wasn't supposed to be able to hear it at all. In fact,
it was an internal signal probably bleeding over from another line.
And when a long distance line was idle, when there was no call on it,
this tone would be being played continuously.
Basically the tone means that the line is free and silence on the line means
there's someone trying to make a call.
So say you're in New York and you want to call La, you pick up your phone,
the circuit's got this tone on it and marking the circuit is idle,
dial the La number.
And at that point your line takes away the tone for just a moment.
It goes silent and La goes, AH,
New York wants to make a phone call and then la drops its tone and the New York
and La machines talk to each other.
[inaudible]
so that's one discovery.
Another discovery is that you can dial a phone by just having the hook switch,
that little button where you hang up, tap that three times delta number three,
seven times, dial the number seven. And so then Joe thought wheat pulses,
tones. Maybe if you were to make a little bursts of a tone.
So something like
Joe's demonstrate it on a web show called hacks or radio.
You were nine. If you were to do something like that,
maybe you could actually dial a call with my math
and you could actually make a comment.
That's exactly how the phone system used to send calls back and forth.
That was its language, if that's right. Joe Learned how to speak telephone,
which was amazing. I mean, I think that's amazing. Um,
but isn't he just dialing the phone with his lips as opposed to using his
fingers? Yes, true.
But Joe made one more little discovery that would change his life forever.
See if you first dialed a a number, like long distance information, five, five,
five, one, two, one, two. The telephone company doesn't charge for call for him.
So what he figured out was that once you get the operator on the line,
if you then whistled to disconnect, but only for a little bit,
only for a second or two, the line nearly disconnects.
But it doesn't all the way,
it just sits in this kind of limbo waiting for instructions waiting to be used.
Huh. And you
can we route your call by whistling the digits and wanting to dial and make a
free call because the phone company again thinks that you're still connected to
information and it's not charging you for that.
He was like having an unlimited plane ticket to anywhere Joe could call anywhere
he wanted for free.
Coming up and explore in the number you have. Code is not connected. Listen
[inaudible]
and so he started calling all over the world,
even broken number numbers just to hear the different voices,
the number [inaudible] gang.
I used to do this by the way, did you really?
My sister and I would get on the phone. We could call information.
That was a free service. Yeah, and we said, hello information.
Can you please contact with Toronto and then we get the Toronto operator.
Let me see. Trying to, could you please get us in comp project with Churchill,
Ontario, which is way up north. Then the Trisha lady would come on and say,
can you please put us in touch with [inaudible] New York in a workplace and they
did transfer you to the northern space.
We would be talking to a person in the Arctic for nothing. Wow.
It was the sense of, of going long distance for free.
Now imagine you're a blind kid doing that in an abusive home.
You can't even run away. I think the phone represented freedom.
Um, it represented a place that was under his control.
He could be an expert in it, you know, it was,
it was a place that he could do all sorts of things that maybe he wasn't so
easily able to do in real life.
[inaudible]
so what happens next?
So things get a little bit better for Joe as he gets older.
His mom takes him out of the Catholic school.
Once she finds out that the nuns are beating him,
he never told his parents about the sexual abuse.
He gets more and more savvy with the phone.
And then finally he goes off to the University of South Florida where he starts
showing off.
It started out,
Joe told a student that he can whistle a free phone call and the students said,
no, you can't. And he said, want bet. So they bet a dollar.
And Joe whistled a long distance call for him.
And before long there were crowds of 40 kids who were following them around
wanting to see him do this parlor trick. And,
and then he whistled up this one particular fateful call,
he's trying to whistle somebody in New York, which is area code five one six
[inaudible]
but instead had wound up in Canada, which is five one four.
Yeah,
you can see if you're whistling calls,
you could easily get off by one or two beeps.
So he wound up talking to an operator in Canada and the operator in Canada put
his call through to New York, uh,
but then actually managed to listen to the call.
And then the student was talking about the,
the wizkid who put the call through to him for him and telephone companies.
Security ended up tracing it back to a University of South Florida.
It was just a gossipy operator who told on him and gossipy or security
conscious, depending on how you view it, fun ruining. That's how I view.
So Joe's busted,
he nearly gets kicked out of school and the whole thing causes just enough of a
stir that people find out.
The local school newspaper wrote an article about it and it got picked up by a
wire service. Next thing you know,
there are newspaper articles and publicity and [inaudible].
Here's the weird thing. As news travels,
did you see this article about the blind kid in Florida? You can do this.
It turns out Joe wasn't alone, right,
Brian?
There were all of these other Joan Grossi as out. Yeah.
[inaudible]
the phone system. Two, one, two, three, nine, six you mean I'm not the only one.
You mean there are other people who are interested in this as well.
They weren't whistling.
Some of them would use these little machines called the blue boxes that would
make the tones.
Couple of kids actually modified a toy whistle from a box of captain crunch,
and because Joe got hot, they all started to find out about each other.
That really ended up being, I think,
a point for a whole generation of fun fleets. This is NBC nightly news phone.
What phone freaks. Phone freaks will tell you.
Phone freaking began with a blind young man named Joe and Bresha.
One thing he discovered was that he could whistle his own call
and before long people are actually calling John Grassi inm network starts to
form n the phone freaks started finding
broken vacant member recordings. So for example,
you dial in non-working number and you get the usual telephone company record.
Well, did you have recently non working number?
But it turns out some of those were broken in such a way that the volume level
was very low and if multiple people called the same number, they could talk.
Right?
Oh God, yeah. Wow.
Teenage kids would call. Anyway, it turned into a party line,
kind of an annoying one because you had this announcement that was repeating
every 30 seconds by my number,
but it's still allowed teenage kids to talk to one another at the department of
no. Wow.
Oh, so this is it. I mean he found his tribe basically. Yeah.
And he would call the conference lines and talk with them about phones and
freaking and everything.
But that really wasn't what he was after and I think it's an interest
something because,
so say you're a lonely kid and you start playing around with the phone or you
start playing around with scrabble or whatever it is,
you get really obsessed about something right through the magic of that thing.
You end up meeting other people.
You sort of have a choice to make at that point.
Choice one is embrace the community. Choice two is,
Oh that's nice.
It's great that there are other people and I get some stuff from that.
But you know, I found this thing, life telephone, my scrabble set,
whatever it is I'm obsessed by and I'm still obsessed by it and it seems to me
like he sort of made the choice to go for the thing.
It's not that he didn't like the community,
but he was still searching for something. Hmm.
Esquire magazine, 1971
march of 1971 is when you moved to Memphis, right. Reporter
and that month he had done very little long distance phone freaking from his own
phone. He had begun to apply for a job with the phone company.
Yeah. He went there intending to get a job and be a man as he [inaudible]
and he wanted to stay away from anything illegal in Garcia. Quote,
any kind of job, we'll do anything as menial as the most lowly operator.
That's probably all they'd give me because I'm blind.
He wanted to be a telephone man. He wanted to take his lunchbox to work.
He wanted to get a paycheck. He wanted to be a real person like everybody else.
This is Stephen Gip, one of Joe's best friends. He lived in a couple of places.
The first one was, you know, just imagine the skid row. I mean, it was, it was,
you know,
you woke up one morning when the heat went out and he stepped on a dead frozen
rack cause he had ended up sleeping in his coat. I mean, you know,
that's all we could afford and uh, he can't get arrested in Memphis. Uh,
you know, he can't get a job to save his life.
So he decides to get arrested literally by um,
doing this very,
very elaborate public freak where he gets a bunch of his freaking friends on a
conference call and he starts dialing up for an embassy's like the armed
services and Moscow like and pretended that he was calling as a radio host and
that all of his friends were his studio audience. Hi, this is, you know, sold.
So from this radio show,
do you have time to talk and be on the air with us today? Oh Great.
Cause he wanted to stay on the phone line so that the phone company could trace
him cause his, he, he says they're not really speeding. You know,
you wanted to give them a lot of time to catch up.
Two weeks later is when he walked out the door and you know the FBI came up and
said Joseph and [inaudible] and why did he do this?
Cause he was trying to try and get the phone company pay attention.
That's right. That's right.
In the hopes that he would get a free meal in jail or no,
in the hopes that he would get a job with the phone company. That's right.
What a weird way to go about it. And amazingly it worked.
Yeah, he got four job offers, all phone jobs.
So he got a job at a little independent Millington telephone company and he
started cleaning telephones.
Anything from cleaning phones to servicing equipment,
any kind of job will do,
but any kind of job wouldn't do. You really didn't like it.
It's that kind of thing where you realize your lifelong dream and then you
think, wait, I can dream anything I want.
I can dream bigger than this.
And so in 1975 76 whatever,
he moved to Denver, Denver, where every dream is in reach,
paid for by the committee to promote Denverton.
He started hobnobbing with all the telephone guys and going into the public
utilities commission and that's when he stopped working for mountain bell
mountain bell telephone. And that's when he started freaking for the man.
And so he worked as a network troubleshooter and at this point he had such an
intimate knowledge of all the little clicks and pops of the phone system that he
could tell from those noises what was going on in the network,
how your car was being routed.
There was a problem somewhere along the line that the problem was maybe even
where it was. Wow. Strictly from listening strictly from excellent.
This was listening to the dial tone times near
[inaudible] should
have to go through
and he demonstrated his powers on the New York radio station. WBAI there was,
there was a show called off the hook.
Okay. Good old bang.
[inaudible]
would just stick. Click now it'll answer briefly.
That was a little funny. CML,
it'll stay like that as long as you want to stay on it. [inaudible] nice sound.
I didn't know. Oh,
it drops off on number five efs. I forgot.
Wow. He's like a Jedi master. Yeah, he's made it. Yeah,
and so he quit what gave up the job for his friend.
But it sounds like you finally got what he wanted.
I think like he became the master of the world that he had escaped into,
but he never really dealt with the world that he had escaped from.
Meaning like that little boy,
that broken little boy that he was still needed a kind of fixing in a way that
wasn't going to be, you know, no job is really gonna solve that. So,
so my time,
he moves to Minneapolis on June 12th cause six,
12 was Minneapolis area code and he basically becomes a kid again,
you know, just everything you did from that point on,
other than his phone had to do with children.
He'd visit with children who were terminally ill.
You just visit with children in general.
I've got a recording at home affect those, listening to it.
Last night before he came to the interview,
I was laughing and giggling because all these little girls were coming up and
they were saying, hi. Hi.
[inaudible]
I'm going. I could hear the parents in the back saying, don't sit on his toys.
And uh, you know, he acts, you start talking about little, little more to me,
you know, about his being abused. And you know, missing out on his childhood.
And he was at a seminar at uplifting seminar and the instructor said something
on the order of, I'm paraphrasing, like, tell me how you feel right now.
And he screamed and yelled and threw up his arms and said, joy bubbles.
And in that moment he decided that he would actually go by that name,
joy bubbles. You may changed his name legally changed his name to joy bubbles,
all one word.
And it was around this time that he decided and announced that he wasn't going
to be an adult anymore.
His old name in his past was gone and he wanted to be five years old,
five years old, forever.
[inaudible]
and then he started doing this.
Gosh, it's may already. Well,
I'm glad you called stories and stuff. You're storyteller,
joy bubble here in Minneapolis, Minnesota.
You know those recordings I mentioned at the beginning,
they're all from the show that Joe recorded every week.
He called it stories
and stuff. And instead of broadcasting it,
he'd record the episodes to an answering service and then you'd call a number
and listen to it on the phone.
Hello kids shy adults. I think the title is part tiled and part adult.
Well, hello, I am. Hello. If this story isn't stuff
you've read stories and stuff. This is Joey bubbles here in Minneapolis.
That's all one word. No, don't you dare split it. Joey bubbles.
And this may be too armchair psychoanalytical,
but it really feels as though it's the kind of show that he needed to hear when
he was a kid.
Like the new five-year-old was trying to go back and say something to the
five-year-old from the early fifties.
Something akin to it's okay in the end it's going to be okay.
Yeah, there is help if you'd like an American, every friend,
a bunch of 'em come that are just looking for somebody to love and play with and
talk to. And so all you have to do is any quiet day,
just get quiet and ask for one that the kind get like they'll come and uh,
they'll be with you for as long as you want them. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
thanks to producer Shawn Cole and to Steven Gibbs and Phil Lapsley,
who is now finished a book on freaking.
I'm chat up and run. I remember Krulwich. Thanks for listening.